do you think athletes like yourself
while you're playing should be getting
involved in these cultural and political
discussions or should they just play the
game
here's where I stand on it I stand on
with sport if you're in the game and
you're coming off the field of the court
and you're getting interviewed I can
keep it a sport so
how do you think you played I'm not
gonna go political rant after I asked
that question
in your personal time in your personal
forums by all means go for your life
that's for you to do whatever you want
whatever you're passionate about I think
in that two hours we all as a society
are so ingrained in politics and what's
going on here your local your state your
federal World politics Russia Ukraine
we're also ingrained in every single
moment of the day social media I think
the beauty of sport has always been it's
a two to three hour release to get away
from that now we're bombarded and every
commercial break and jerseys and you
know people not standing for the anthem
all that kind of stuff I think it's too
much that's my opinion on it but I think
you know it's irie or even Angela Logan
wants to be political once you're
outside of that little bubble and you
want to go on your social forums and you
want to do you know podcasts like this
by all means I'm all for it but the
biggest thing with the NBA and the NFL
at sporting leagues all around the world
is if it's the right kind of politics
we'll help you promote it so right
release and and you know the LM or if
it's this or if it's that all for it but
if there's someone that's got a
different view or and has legitimate
reasons for it
yeah you know in his Tanner I knew as
soon as you were the shoes he was in
some trouble you know he was obviously
getting older
um is he a superstar player no but
should he still be a vet Min guy for
another three or four years of course he
should but the team looks at it like hey
this is going to be a guy painting two
to three four or five million a year and
he's probably gonna be a bit of a
distraction we'll just we'll just move
on right that's the way our team would
look at it
um where the NBA tapped those teams on
the shoulders probably so who knows but
it's just it just it just always
bothered me that it was you know if
you're if you're a mainstream you know
agenda that's being pushed yes we'll
hold you up but as soon as you go
against that law you must be some sort
of yes or whatever it is right and that
really bothered me and I on top of that
just just to finish that on top of that
I know like this isn't something I'm
guessing
there's a lot of players in the NBA that
don't believe the shoot they're
promoting period and off with some
Locker to Locker played with them
against them with some whatever I know
what they say in the room is a 180 to
what they're saying publicly like I had
teammates that were super religious
really Conservative Christian religious
right and they're out there you know
saying some things that are completely
opposite to what they are lockering with
their families
do you buy them
who knows I mean there's there's money
to be made there's there's they're
trying to feed their family as they all
goes but I draw the line on you know
when you're preaching to the masses you
better be living the life that you're
preaching and I know for a lot of guys
that's that's not the case
it's really interesting you make that
point because I know it's a different
sport but you're an Aussie so you'll
know this guys the case of Israel fellow
who is a devout Christian and he came
out and was honest about what devout
Christians think about gay people
and that wasn't accepted
yeah where to go play overseas in fact
um and yes that's all if we're going to
allow freedom of speech and freedom to
beat wherever you are or if that's his
point of view look as long as he's not
condoning violence or saying that you
know they should be shattered or stoned
or shunned from society
um you know that's not right at all and
that's that's where we draw the line but
it wasn't that my beliefs are America's
for a mountain linen you have to respect
those beliefs you know that they're his
beliefs and he has a rightful rights for
those beliefs you don't have to disagree
or disagree with him but I you know I'm
all for having different points of view
there's many people that I greatly
respect that I disagree with but that's
fine that's that's what you're supposed
when you become an a t a child to a teen
to an adult that's supposed to be an
attribute that you have as an adult
someone disagreed with me
that's fine take a deep breath we have a
discussion about it and you might learn
something new and vice versa but you can
it's okay to disagree today's society
it's not especially when it comes to
public
uh Mantra and stuff that the mainstream
is pushing you can't disagree with that
and I've been a big part of that here in
Australia the trans ideology and there's
a big issue here in Australia with with
men infiltrating women's sport and
women's spaces and I'll be the advocate
for that for young girls to support
because I have people reaching out to me
like that I like I don't have a voice
I'm scared to say anything but you know
my daughter just got knocked out by a
guy in the under 16s rugby who's playing
in the women's league what can I do
about it I'm trying to help these people
and I feel really bad and and people
think I'm doing this to some
some side with side hustle or gain or
whatever it's like well there'll be
those people some some news I lose out
on marketing businesses I lose out on on
making a bit more cash on marketing and
promos and speaking gigs people like
that would still not touching just just
in case someone protested I saw or gets
mad at us or whatever so I'm going to
continue to speak out on on stuff that's
just utterly ridiculous
foreign